We're going to start today with a media story
I'm going to present to you today the epitome
of right wing media dishonesty and distortion,
and it's going to be specifically talking
about the economy and employment numbers,
so last week, as often happens in the first
few days of a new month, we get the jobs numbers
from the previous month.
We got them late last week from June.
There were totally unremarkable job numbers
for June, more or less, a continuation of
similar numbers that we saw.
What we saw under President Obama, 213,000
jobs were added during the Obama Administration.
Two hundred and 14,000 jobs per month were
added.
That was during Obama's second term.
The unemployment rate went up slightly to
four percent.
Very small change.
I've been telling you for years and years
how the unemployment rate is calculated.
It's been calculated the same way for a very
long time.
Very often when you have low unemployment
numbers under a Democratic president, you
will see Republicans say when people stopped
looking for work, they're no longer count
that is unemployed, so the number doesn't
mean anything.
And then all of a sudden when a Republican
has low unemployment numbers, Republicans
seem to completely forget that they were critical
of how that number is formulated when it was
Barack Obama or a democrat.
What we do often see Republicans talk about
when there is a Democrat in the White House,
is the number of people who are not working.
Sometimes this is used interchangeably with
the labor force participation rate and I've
been telling you for a year after year after
year that the raw number of people that are
working or the run number of people that are
not working, the labor force participation
rate, they are very often misleading, sometimes
useless, and almost 100 percent of the time
those numbers are used for political gain
by whoever is looking to distort the reality
of the economy.
It communicates almost nothing about two,
the about the economy to say x number of people
are working and the headline that drudge report,
right wing propagandists drudge report ran
when the June numbers came out.
Red Record $155 million employed.
This is presumably the number of people with
jobs in the United States.
I am also going to show you the headline from
the same website, drudge report on March eighth
of 2013 when Barack Obama was president.
The headline read 89 point 3 million, not
working the number of people not who are unemployed,
but people who aren't in the labor force.
Right?
So when drudge said $89, million not working,
that included retired people that included
full time college students, it included stayed
home.
Parents who don't need to work because they
are well off financially and what you need
to understand to realize how you are being
manipulated or there are attempts to manipulate
you with these numbers.
Remember that the population of the United
States has been going up forever.
At many times in American history, there have
been record numbers of people working at the
same time that you had record numbers of people
not working.
You can display either number to make a political
point and case in point, as I told you a month
ago, maybe it was two months ago, there are
also a record number of people not working
right now, just as right now we have, if you
believe the numbers from drudge report, uh,
more people than ever working because there
are more people in the United States then
ever before the numbers mean nothing.
And following drudge report, right wing media
just jumped all over this thing as if it was
some miracle and I hate to break it to them,
but sometimes record numbers of people working
isn't a positive thing and I'll explain the
percentage, not the number.
The percentage of people over 85 years of
age, 85 or older working today is very high
back in 2006 before the recession.
Two point six percent.
Of those 85 or older, we're working two point
six percent today.
You have almost twice as many people over
age 85 working there.
Part of the victorious great economy have
record numbers of people working.
Right?
Well, hold on.
Let's just think about it for a second.
Some people who are over age 85 are working
because they want to.
Some people over age 85 are working because
85 year olds are slightly healthier today
than they were in 2006 on average.
Although there hasn't actually been that big
of a change, but overall when you read that
part of the record, number of people working
is a higher than ever rate of 85 plus year
old.
Do you have to think about it and realize,
wait a second, there's more 85 year olds than
ever working because they have to because
wages are stagnant because cost of living
goes up as wages are stagnant and pat, this
is how the right wing media spins these bogus
narratives.
They put up a number record one $55 million
working.
It means nothing and it becomes the talking
point for the month of July.
Yeah.
I remember shortly after the trump administration
began, sean spicer was saying that the president
didn't believe the strong jobs numbers under
Obama, but now that trump is president, he
obviously does believe them, but I mean at
that was at least delivered somewhat tongue
in cheek.
I guess the hypocrisy when he said that it
wasn't clear whether it was like a 90 percent
joke or a 50 percent joke, but there was some
understanding of the political nature of the
numbers was the drudge report.
They're trying to deceive you and exactly
what they succeeded with.
Many of us do.
Well, unfortunately the audience that it is
being delivered to is eating it up like it
is being just ladle fed to them and it's it,
it, it's any small amount of critical analysis
applied to that tells you that it is merely
spoon feeding nonsense to a hungry audience.
That's all it is.